well the intelligence we receive uh
tells us a very clear uh story about
that uh russia is not withdrawing
its forces but uh
repositioning them
and
and that we can expect uh uh reinforced
russian uh uh military um effort in the
donbass region so so russia continues to
pursue a military outcome of this
conflict and we
have to expect
more human suffering and continued the
shelling of ukrainian cities including
kiev
has putin's invasion highlighted what
some have described as nato's
fundamental
impotence he's not scared of nato it's
not stopping him
well nato's main responsibility is to
protect
all nato allies 30 nato allies 1 billion
people
and we have successfully done so for
more than 70 years
because no nato ally have suffered a
military attack since this alliance was
established
and to make sure that that also is the
case in the future
we have reinforced our presence in the
eastern part of the alliance and i would
like to commend the united kingdom for
leading those efforts
the united kingdom leads one of the bat
groups who are deployed in the baltic
region
and the united states and all the nato
allies have also stepped up so so
we are there to prevent an attack on
nato countries and we have done so for
more than 70 years and also throughout
this crisis at the same time we provide
support
to ukraine which is not a nato ally but
a highly valued partner and an allies
are stepping up their support to ukraine
can i put to you the words of um of the
former commander of british land forces
general cynic parker who spoke this
morning he said and this is a quote from
him nato has been defeated nato's bluff
was called we were unable to stop the
russians trampling over ukraine we need
a smaller coalition of nations who can
start to develop a counter strategy to
putin
would you welcome that as a smaller
group perhaps of nato members that form
a sort of offensive coalition would you
welcome it could it exist alongside nato
because i think nato is doing what we
are supposed to do uh and that is uh to
protect and defend all allies the whole
the whole idea of nato is that an attack
on one ally will trigger the response
from the whole alliance one for all and
all for one and to demonstrate that not
only words but indeed we have
implemented the biggest reinforcement to
our collective defense since uh
or in a generation since the end of the
cold war and we have successfully
protected and defended all nato allies i
think it is important to understand the
difference between a nato ally and then
partners as for instance ukraine
we have for decades
they are not covered by our security
guarantees but of course we have
provided support to ukraine the united
kingdom and all the nato allies have
trained tens of thousands of ukrainian
troops which are now on the front line
fighting the invading russian forces
we have for years equipped them with
modern military equipment so the
ukrainian army is bigger
better equipped better trained and
better led now that ever before and of
course this combined with the courage of
the ukrainian men and women in uniform
this is the reason why they're able to
push back and to resist invading russian
forces
but in in terms of what nato stands for
and what nato has promised to do and
achieve if you're dealing with other
nations who don't then follow the rules
like for example russia moscow promised
to respect the sovereignty integrity and
and independence of all states in an act
that it signed with nato in 1997.
they've clearly breached that shouldn't
that act even be declared null and void
which it still hasn't been
because we are acting uh
but again i think you need to understand
the difference between nato allies they
we
they we actually
issue or we we have absolute security
guarantees we will defend every inch of
nato territory and we demonstrate that
every day and that's also the reason why
no nato allied country has been attacked
uh uh when then of course what russia
does in uh in ukraine the brutal nation
of ukraine is absolutely unacceptable
and that's also the reason why why we
are implementing unprecedented economic
sanctions on russia
why we are stepping up our support our
military support for uh for ukraine nato
allies provides
significant support again uk is playing
a key role and also
humanitarian and
and financial support
so we are doing a lot and and i think
that russia totally underestimated both
the strength of the ukrainian army
but also the unity of nato and the
international community in imposing
sanctions and also in providing support
to ukraine
can i ask you what you made of sir
jeremy fleming from gchq's speech today
in australia are talking about
disorganization low morale and the
russian troops putin's advisers being
afraid to tell him what is actually
going on um is it your assessment too
that this internal or disorganization
and low morale is one of the key reasons
that russia is failing on the ground
yes
president putin has made two big
mistakes one is to underestimate the
strength of the ukrainian people armed
forces
and the ukrainian political leadership
and then he has totally overestimated
the strength of its own
military uh forces armed forces
um and of course we have seen all the
logistical problems the supply problems
and
uh several examples of low morale within
the russian armed forces but at the same
time we need to realize that russia is
is continuing to wage war
and has uh demonstrated that they will
uh not only to inflict pain and
suffering on other people but actually
also
take pain and continue
to wage war despite the heavy losses
they have suffered i think this partly
reflects the reality that russia is a
autocratic society
where people are afraid of
speaking the truth to uh the leaders and
actually are inclined to tell the
leaders what they want to hear and
that's that's not the best
basis for making good decisions so
president putin this is his war and the
war has been a big strategic mistake for
russia
but but would should we the western
public also be skeptical about what our
leaders and what our
spy catchers like gchq tell us given
that this is
very much an information war isn't it
i think we always should be very
say uh vigilant and assess all kind of
information we receive but the big big
difference between uh russia and nato
allied countries united kingdom uh is
that we are democratic societies we have
checks and balances and we have a free
and independent press and which are
actually on the ground in ukraine and uh
and which are reporting about uh
political discussions within our own
countries so
free and open societies with a free and
independent press
proves more resilient prove more
stronger than autocratic systems like
the one we see in russia
and one final question very briefly just
just coming back to what i put you about
general sinic parker about
he believes there should be a smaller
coalition that is offensive
do you not get frustrated inside nato do
you not think you know our hands are
tied we can't
we can't take action in ukraine we are a
defensive alliance do you not wish that
there was an organization that was
standing up for what nato stands for but
was separate to nato that could take
offensive action
nato is standing up for what nato stands
for we do that by providing
unprecedented support to ukraine we've
done so for many many years and
imposing unprecedented sanction costs on
on russia and by
an historic strong reinforcement or
presence in eastern part of the alliance
protecting all allies preventing any
attack on any nato allied country
i think we have to understand that if
nato allies as an alliance or individual
allies as a smaller group coalition or
the willing
directly confronted russian troops in
ukraine
sending in
troops on the ground or planes in the
air
that will most likely
almost certainly
lead to a full-fledged military
confrontation between nato and russia a
full-fledged war in europe and then the
suffering we see in ukraine uh we would
see just many many times the same but in
many more countries uh so uh it will be
even worse for the civilian population
even worse
for our cities we see more destruction
more death so nato has responsibility to
support ukraine but also to prevent this
conflict from escalating and any idea of
a small group of nato allies going into
that conflict is dangerous it will lead
to escalation and more death and more
destruction so i i don't think that's a
good idea at all
very clear jen stoltenberg uh secretary
general of nato really good to talk to
you thank you for joining us today
thank you so much for having me